what in particular did you want to
explore with alien covenant soon as you
say talk about creation you're opening
up all kinds of things because you're
opening up God superior being who made
who how did we exist are we enacted
biological accident and along with that
you've got a double gang with which has
got the AI chip he is seriously
dangerous for you Michael I mean I must
personally been a pleasure to finally
get to act with someone that is of your
caliber but were you creating the to the
two different days I mean while so was
it a challenge because he doesn't have
that human emotion there's a lot of
boring prep work that happens in the
kitchen living room at home you know
before he sort of get on set but I kept
him you know as a sort of blank canvas
for the audience to fill in the gaps
with them so they were looking at him in
your thinking is your friend is he so
what what's he thinking what point does
it hit you that you're in an alien movie
and hits you like 50 times a day or
maybe the rest of your life and he is
the creator the engineer of this series
I love the way of exploring a lot of
themes with aliens there is a there is a
continuation of some of those ideas from
Prometheus there but then also all of
the like rip-roaring mayhem from the
original film and so it's kind of nice
balance of sort of big ideas and just
crazy pure entertainment
it's like rare for a film like this that
actually can scare the hell out of you
but then I so leave you thinking about
creation and you know where whom who
created us and what are we going to
create and what will they create it's a
hard thing to sort of weave to be able
to you know propose these questions and
scare the little you what keeps you in
thoose II astok about these movies I've
never worked it in my life yeah no
seriously I love it I get Mego great a
new day but no I love what I do so
passionate about what I do
[Music]
you